[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily with me
Neil Patterson today on the show I'll be
speaking to someone that I'm sure you
will recognize both from his appearances
on the podcast but also of course for
the work he does for this guy News
Channel he has over the past year
covered a range of subjects as diverse
as the cost of living crisis the tanking
of the pound the guilt yields the
fantastic and wonderful world of mass
production of tomatoes but at the same
time he is also found the opportunity to
write himself a book the book is
entitled Material World a substantial
story of our past and future and our
guest is of course our economics and
data editor Ed Conway
Material World explain the conceit of
this book because you take you take a
sense of what six six materials and and
do what with them exactly so so
obviously it's the Madonna it's the
Madonna song Material World actually
that one had compared to me you know
we're living in a material world
um and yeah this basically that the idea
was to kind of have a slightly bottom-up
view of the world
um in the and the way it fits together
and I've chosen six substances you've
got sand you've got salt you've got oil
you've got lithium you've got copper
you've got iron but between those
substances it's not an exhaustive list
of course
um so many of the different parts of the
world that we rely on that we touch
every day that's where they come from
and when we think about you know the
universe that we inhabit
some of the time we kind of think about
the processes that make the phone that
you might be listening to this on or
indeed the kind of the different you
know your earphones or whatever it is
you think a little bit about that stuff
but where about you know what about
where it starts in the ground so you
know a lot of people think about silicon
chips where did that actually begin its
life what did we literally tear out of
the ground and what did we do to it in
order to create a silicon chip use that
as an example tell me yeah because it
turned out there's lots of books about
semiconductors lots of them very good
but they mostly just focus on one bit at
the very end you know where you already
have your silicon your scratching or you
there's something called photography
you're etching different transistors
onto them it's a really complex process
it's amazing it is nanotechnology you
are literally shifting atoms in order to
create these devices we are using every
day and you know kind of Moaning at the
fact they're not loading fast enough
there's nanotechnology going on in there
there's nanotechnology going on in the
devices that you're listening to this on
so that's amazing but equally amazing it
turns out is the fact that that's only
part of the story that's only the tip of
the iceberg but explain the utility in
me a smartphone owner understanding all
of that what what why do I need to know
how the materials that produced the
semiconductors in my phone actually work
I think we would have more respect for
the items that we're using on a daily
basis and perhaps have slightly less
disposable Society if we knew a bit more
about what went into making them by
disconnecting ourselves from that from
that process and we have just
disconnected ourselves partly because we
don't make as much of this stuff in this
country in particular as we're used to
partly because you need fewer people to
make things to get stuff out of the
ground to turn it into the products we
need and part of this the point of of
this journey I've been on is trying to
to find out for myself what did it take
to to make the batteries that we're
using in our electric cars where did
that stuff come out of the ground what
did we do to it to turn it into a
product and the answer it turns out is
so many different pieces of work so much
energy goes into converting these things
we emit so much carbon just to make to
make stuff to make stuff and I feel like
in a lot of the debate that we talk
about when people are talking about
climate change they're talking about
carbon emissions all of these things
this is quite a new prism through which
to see it because you're seeing that
even simple things take a lot of energy
and a lot of carbon emissions to make
and so we need to think about that as
well it is environmental concerns it is
this push to Net Zero and there is an
awful lot in here that I think would
suggest to many people that Net Zero is
going to be awfully awfully difficult to
get towards it's going to be tougher
than it's certainly tougher than I
expected it would be you know having
started and you know looked into this
and
um it is an enormous goal and I don't
think you know when we would sign up to
it and set it into law when Theresa May
sign it into law just before she she
left as prime minister I don't know if
if she indeed the cabinet indeed many
people out there in the general public
were aware of just quite how
far-reaching this would be as a goal it
is it is a noble and honorable goal but
we also have to be kind of honest about
the extent to which it's going to be
incredibly hard and why is it going to
be hard it's going to be hard because if
you think about this world that we
inhabit with all the products whether
it's smartphone whether it's simple
stuff whether it's Plastics whether it's
the house that you live in the steel
that holds it up the copper wires that
come in there all of this stuff is
basically the Bedrock of of Our Lives of
modern civilization because without a
lot of that stuff we're in big trouble
all of it took carbon emissions to make
all of it all of it there are no
exceptions and in order to get to Net
Zero it is not just about building lots
of wind turbines although that is a big
part of it it is about going through all
of these different processes that
constitute you know the fruit of
centuries of research of scientific
Endeavor of manufacturing and
reimagining them we have to redo the the
Industrial Revolution or the various
industrial revolutions that have already
happened all over again and that is
massive it's also exciting because
there's opportunities are plenty there
but it's just the scale of it I think
isn't as you know enormously understood
you've got to be pretty anti-environment
to push for all the materials that you
need to to turn those into a net zero
can't a network economy you need more
you need more copper you need more
lithium you should be quite blousy about
the mining don't you well have you been
there it's this this is the Paradox and
this is the most uncomfortable thing but
there is no roots plausible route to
eliminating carbon emissions while also
keeping everyone in the world in the
standard of living that they all expect
without having to do a lot more
exploitation of the Earth
and you just won't do it if you don't do
that and that's not that's not kind of
being defeatist that's just saying in
order if you want batteries you've got
to get the lithium from somewhere you've
got to get the cobot from somewhere as
well the nickel the manganese all the
other things if you want wind turbines
you need a lot of Steel
and right now we don't have a
particularly good way of mass producing
steel we don't have a good way at all of
mass producing steel without a lot of
carbon emissions you've got to you know
make fiberglass that goes into wind
turbine sales where you've got to make
the glass and right now what do we make
glass with we make glass with big
furnaces that are mostly powered by
natural gas and
there are all of these Paradox Net Zero
is doable it's just hard I have to admit
that the environmental stuff that the
climate change stuff is absolutely
fascinating to me and it's stuff we have
indeed covered on other podcasts but
what was also something of a revelation
to me is when you start talking about
the the great game that is now taking
place between the superpowers and indeed
between lesser powers for control of
these resources yeah it's I mean and
it's and it's happening now and and
there is one country which is
particularly leading the charge which is
China yeah they are aware that around
the world our focus is shifting from
Petro economies when you look at the
story of the 20th century you know that
a lot of it was defined by where the oil
was you know that was it including for
that matter and there's a long bit about
this including you know in the second
world war it was kind of a war about oil
and who controlled the oil and part of
the reason Hitler struggled was a long
side tactical decisions was that he
didn't have enough oil so China now is
very conscious of that and has been
pushing for access to this other Suites
of materials so whereas in the past it
was very much about oil it was very much
about coal now you know it's copper it's
lithium it's Cobalt it's all of these
materials China is trying to take
possession trying to own a lot of these
mines it is doing a lot of the refining
of the materials so we talk you know
people talk about how it's striking how
much China dominates the market for
things like rare earth materials so it's
massively important and right now what's
happening you know in Taiwan right now
what's happening with like the noises
between the US and the UK and China it
is getting more and more bellicose so we
are making those noises we are making it
more difficult potentially to trade with
the place from where we're getting where
from where we're you know we're reliant
on it for the stuff that we need to get
to Net Zero so there's a paradox there's
a lot of paradox but you can flip it on
its head I mean China is relying on the
money that gets sent to Rich completely
either to buy the reason please I mean
it is this curious aspect of geopolitics
to me that you've got as you say this
rather bellicose language the butting of
heads that's going one in diplomatic
channels but all of these countries are
so closely linked to each other by these
resources I mean we talked I think in
the past about Somaliland there was a
there was a famine in Somaliland because
they couldn't get access to Green
because the grain was stored in silos in
Ukraine and wasn't getting out of the
country this interconnectivity is
remarkable yeah and it's all and and it
it's a greater interconnectivity than
than one even thinks because you know
fertilizer as well you know that you
know in Somaliland and many parts of
sub-Saharan Africa around the world as
well you know you need fertilizer and
fertilizer ultimately has to come from
somewhere and a lot of that fertilizer
also comes from Russia Ukraine places
like that a lot of fertilizer by the way
and this is another one of the the kind
of striking things I hadn't quite
appreciated until I I did this um
research is that you know half of the
world population would not be able to
would not be here would not be alive
were it not for the fertilizer that we
make nitrogen-based fertilizer so our
bodies are literally in part
artificially fixed through nitrogen you
know for nitrogen from the air
um and turned fertilizer which goes into
the food or indeed goes into the kind of
food stuff for for livestock which we
then eat we are all literally made of
this stuff what is fertilizer made from
it's made from natural gas we use
natural gas to make the fertilizer and
so again we're in this naughty awkward
situation where the thing that is very
unfashionable right now turns out to be
pretty important for the survival of
humanity it's not just about burning it
in order to to you know to to turn
turbines which can create power or
indeed to get your car going it is
feeding us and
that the upshot of that is that you
start to see the world in a slightly
different prism it's not black and white
you know it's this enormous gray area
and I think frankly I think a lot of
people I hope listening will realize
that of course that's the way the world
is but a lot of the stuff has been
presented
you know including dare I say in some of
the media as black and white heroes and
villains here are the bad guys who are
the Google and it's not like that it
really isn't and when you kind of strip
all that stuff away and just look at
these materials look at the products
look at our lives then you kind of see
it's much more complicated and much more
interesting than that but at the end at
the end of writing this book just as a
as a cheeky question did you have more
or less respect for organizations like
just stop oil Extinction Rebellion
oh well that's a bit of a loaded
question isn't it it is a little sorry
but you understand why I'm asking no I
do because as you see heroes and
villains is very much the theme of the
day when it comes to environmental but
there's there's a really so there's a
really sensible point that just stop oil
that's at the core of what just double
they're talking about which is saying
that you know right now
you know maybe we'll be able to make it
to Net Zero without having to license
New oil fields so we can kind of make do
with the oil fields we've got that's
that's not unreasonable in fact that is
um the International Energy agency's
plan you know they say that's possible
and the International Energy agency is
is is a representative of lots of oil
producers uh and consumers in the west
it's not it is by no means an
environmental movement when I see some
of the protests is the tenor of and I
understand why people have to
communicate like this but the tenor of
we are all about to you know we're all
going to hell we're all going to die if
we don't do this you know Millions will
die there's very little evidence for for
that and there's very little evidence
for utter catastrophism there is plenty
of evidence that things are not going to
be great and we need to do something
about it but it's that it's that kind of
difference between saying
we need to really sort this out because
it's not it's going to be bad and for
some people it could indeed be very bad
and you need to kind of find ways of of
making their lives kind of manageable
and saying we are facing apocalyptic
catastrophe because we're not and by the
same token we need also just to be
clear-eyed about the the positive sides
we can't eat without the stuff
how then is the United Kingdom
performing in its desire to be more
environmentally friendly you're an
economic geek I'm a political geek and
you know I've heard governments since
before David Cameron was hugging Huskies
talking about their green credentials
and yet where are we in terms of the
renewable sector where are we in terms
of battery production where are we in
pursuit of Net Zero
um we know the answer to this which is
not we're not doing very well no we're
not doing very well in this country we
we and it's not because we don't have
the materials here to to take advantage
of and in the way that America is kind
of Central and South South America Asia
have I mean there's a bit of that yeah
right now actually one of the most
consequential things that's happened in
the past kind of you know 10 20 years is
the fact that the the US discovered how
to to get oil and gas out of out of you
know Shale rocks because it means they
have pretty cheap oil and pretty cheap
gas whereas here in the UK you know we
had the North Sea we've it's not
exhausted by any means but no you know
it's best days are now behind it
um during that period I think the
critical thing is during that period
when we were benefiting from Lots you
know from from a net Surplus in in oil
and gas production
we were actually de-industrializing our
economy rather than kind of making the
most of it our economy was becoming more
reliant on things like Financial
Services on you know other kind of
ancillary services on Tech you know
these These are these are not by any
means kind of the wrong sectors this is
not stuff that we shouldn't be doing but
we just really allowed our entire kind
of industrial sector to wither away all
the dirty staff all the grimy stuff all
the carbon intensive stuff we allowed
that to go off to China we charge really
high energy prices to producers so it
just became unattractive for them to be
in the UK so they pushed it off to China
and other places and the upshot is
we have one of the lowest you know we
have we our carbon emissions have fallen
faster than pretty much anyone else out
there in the developed world it is a
massive
success story in terms of just looking
at Carbon emissions but then you look at
the bigger picture of the UK economy and
a we've de-industrialized lots of you
know when we talk about those areas of
the country that have been hollowed out
when we talk about the Left Behind when
we talk about you know leveling up and
all of that stuff yeah these areas have
been left behind and it is really
difficult what single story would you
pick out of this as the greatest
Revelation the greatest eye-opener that
you had in your travel
I mean there was a moment where there's
quite a lot of stuff it's quite tricky
um but there was a moment where I was
looking I was kind of standing on the
lip of this mine in Chile
um it is the deepest man-made hole in
the world it's like when looking down
it's like looking down into the Grand
Canyon except that we made this we dug
it it's it's more than 100 years old
it's called chuki kamata and
the knowledge that in order to satisfy
our demand for more copper in the future
we would need not just one of these but
three of those Minds knew Grand Canyon
style mines every year to satisfy
the demand for electric cars for for
wind turbines for everything else solar
panels
and when you stare at these things you
think to yourself that is there's no way
we're going to do that and that brings
you to this issue do we realize the
scale of the challenge that we're facing
in the coming years leaving aside all
the
you know the geopolitical difficulty
that we might well be facing
um do we know just how kind of serious
thing we're heading for and I think the
answer is probably no because there are
too few people thinking about the world
in terms of its materials in terms of
where stuff comes from in terms of the
pragmatic reality rather than you know
ideological battles in in Westminster
and thereafter at well look um the book
Material World a substantial story of
our past and future is out now Ed I
don't know and that is your lot for the
deal for today at my thanks of course to
Ed Conley for coming into the studio
this Edition was produced by silent
Apparition our editor is pulse down